aujourd'hui on vient de parler du
samsung galaxy z philippe 4 le dernier
smartphone paix est l'un des derniers
smartphones pliable de samsung c'est
celui-là smartphone à clapet on vient
réduire l'encombrement c'est un peu
différent du z folle de quatre on vient
augmenter l'encombrement ou y augmenter
la taille de l'écran donc ces deux
philosophies qui sont vraiment
différentes et c'est philippe iv il est
vachement intéressant maintenant la
question qu'on se pose c'est est-ce
qu'il faut mieux aller sur le z philippe
iii est ce que le jeune fille 4 à des
avancées qui sont suffisamment
intéressante si bien que si on a un
modèle douanière faudrait-il aller sur
le nouveau si on n'a jamais eu de
smartphones de samsung est ce qu'il faut
aller sur le efficace et vraiment on se
convenir regarde aujourd'hui j'ai tout
vous dire pour ce smartphone tout en
détail mon retour d'expérience le mal
donc on y va vous êtes prêt pas aux
[Musique]
galaxy z fils je continue à dire je
persiste et je signe en ce sens que le
nom c'est compliqué à rallonge est bon
on comprend flip folle folle flip et
puis surtout cela les enfants tout cas
c'est sympa c'est qu'on va retrouver
l'abbé spock édition circonvenir
customiser son flipper on va commencer
par l'ajustement a commencé par parler
de design que c'est tout est très
chouette c'est un smartphone qui est
beau c'est un smartphone ken la gueule
et qui a un plus gros taux d'adoption
que le z fold 4 7 x 2 3 il a un nez en
tout cas qu'ils avaient en tout cas plus
contre l'adoption pourquoi parce que le
z fold il est hyper canon mais il prend
plus de place donc il a bien séduire
d'autres personnes en un peu moins grand
nombre donc ça en fait c'est vraiment
l'objet qui vient démocratiser le
smartphone pliable et comme en plus
samsung leader sur le marché aujourd'hui
c'est ça le soum qui fait le job et si
on veut acheter aujourd'hui en tout cas
en 2022 et je pense que ce sera
sensiblement la même chose en 2023 en
tout cas ici en france en europe peut
probablement dans le reste du monde eh
bien si on veut un smartphone qui se
plie un tarif qui est maîtrisé même si
ça est quand même relativement cher et
bien on va chez samsung et on prend un z
flip et ça c'est vachement rigolo parce
qu'en fait ils sont les seuls sur le
marché alors on passe un peu ce truc là
très rapidement même si à peine
d'annoncer sied sam et sûr du marché de
masse en tout cas ici en france et en
europe c'est samsung et personne d'autre
alors regardez ça c'est juste hyper
canon et je vous parlais de la bespoke
édition alors là j'ai une version
l'avant demi à d'autres couleurs qui
existe là bespoke édition c'est à dire
on prend d'autres smartphones on peut
dire complètement customisée vous venez
me changer la couleur là vous venez de
changer la couleur là vous me changer
également le contour et vous avez
jusqu'à 75 combinaisons différentes donc
c'est vraiment qu'ils choisissent et qui
faites comme vous voulez vous allez sur
le site de samsung jamais d'ailleurs
tous les liens juste en bas d'un
description les bespoke édition coûte un
peu plus cher celui là déjà en normal il
coûte en version 128 go de stockage 1109
euros c'est un certain budget quand même
6169 euros en version 512 1 1289 euros
et si vous voulez la version avec le
bespoke édition vous rajouter 100 euros
de plus et vous passez alors c'est ce
que sur 256 ici et vous êtes à
1209 euros c'est un peu plus cher et
vous dire vraiment le customiser et vous
ne recevez trois semaines après donc il
faut être tranquille il faut avoir un
petit peu de temps par contre vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez rage et
différents exemples vous avez une espèce
de petite couleur un peu framboise tout
ça très sympa ton tournoi je trouve ça
une fois de plus très très très joli et
puis vous avez également d'autres
possibilités on peut venir faire de
couleur différente si on le souhaite
voyait une peu plus dorée peu plus
blanche le contour en échange on sait
que les smartphones c'est aujourd'hui un
objet de mode si vous voulez un bel
objet qui vous ressemblera et d'un poème
de customiser comme vous le souhaitez
pour autant est-ce que ce smartphone est
vraiment intéressant est ce que ce
smartphone est nouveau et différent par
rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière et bien grosso modo la réponse
est oui et non ça y'a que d'un point de
vue purement esthétique qui sont venus
ont retravaillé un petit peu meurent
couper un peu les bords au laser
également toute cette partie est donc il
est un peu plus fin mais lorsqu'on le
prend en main comme ça on n'a pas
l'impression qu'ils ont retravaillé on
n'a pas l'impression qu'ils aient une
vraie modification vous vous en rendez
compte lorsque vous prenez la version de
l'année dernière le samsung galaxy z
fleet 3 que vous mettez celui-là côté
vita voyez un truc mais au delà de ça
c'est quasiment la même chose on garde
le même esprit le même look and feel
c'est à dire que vous avez un petit
écran la vente est plutôt sympa alors il
ya des nouveautés là dessus et je vais y
venir dans quelques instants vous avez
exactement la même proposition avec un
écran intérieur qui souffre qui est
sympa bon ok ça marche très très bien le
lecteur d'empreintes digitales donc là
dessus on l'a vraiment la même
expérience ce qui va venir changer c'est
deux trois petites choses à savoir d'une
d'un point de vue logiciel et d'un point
de vue matériel il ya quand même
quelques évolutions et je voulais tu as
a tout de suite avant toute chose si
vous vous posez la question de la
solitaire bouvet tranquille parce qu'ils
sont nous certifier ans et veritas ans
qui le certifie un minimum de 200 milles
ouvertures et fermetures donc pouvait
l'être en gros ça vous emmène jusqu'à
cinq ans sans aucun problème vous êtes
tranquille vous allez pas vous retrouver
avec une charnière qui va vous lâcher
donc ça c'est plutôt bien fait c'est
exactement la même proposition que vous
aviez l'année dernière mais en mieux
améliorer sans quelques points premier
truc c'est le taux de rafraîchissement
de votre écran interne pour vous le
faire très simple à technologie on a ici
c'est une dalle dynamique amoled 2 x
technologies de samsung sine die lt p ô
le lt p ô vous permet quoi vous permet
d'avoir un taux de rafraîchissement
variable l'année dernière on passait de
dieppe ce donc les hertz est le nombre
d'image que vous allez par seconde donc
si vous avez dit hier ce en une seconde
vous avez 10 images et si vous regardez
par exemple un film une série ont
diverses des images ça va saccager ça va
pas être bien et on monte jusqu'à 120
hertz donc par exemple si vous avez
regardé un film devait être regarder un
film en 50 hertz en 60 hertz se jouent à
des jeux ça peut être du 90 hertz a peut
être du sang verte ça va dépendre des
jeux mais si par exemple vous êtes sur
un truc statique comme ça et bien vous
allez dire du dr c'est en tout cas vous
étiez sûrs du dies jusqu'à l'année
dernière cette année on vient de
descendre un peu plus bas on est sur du
1er jusqu'à 120 hertz ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'en fait lorsque vous
êtes sur un ace en une seconde vous avez
une seule image qui s'affiche à dire que
en une seconde c'est ça qui s'affiche et
ya rien qui bouge parce que ça n'a pas
besoin de changer ce qui pourrait
éventuellement changer c'est l'heure
lorsque le temps de venir défiler mais
pas plus pas plus pas moins donc ça ça
vient faire quoi en fait de diminuer le
nombre de hertz lorsqu'on utilise
quasiment pas ou sur un truc qui est
assez statique comme ça notamment sur la
lecture d'articles et compagnie eh bien
on vient moins consommer on vient de
gagner un peu au niveau de l'autonomie
et l'autonomiste est vraiment pâle pour
une force de samsung galaxy z trip 3
l'année dernière donc ça c'est plutôt
rigolo on retrouve toujours une
expérience extrêmement fluide lorsqu'on
vient jouer à des jeux là je vous le
montre par exemple sur un petit strike 9
allée à plat on va se faire ça voyez
c'est extrêmement fluide sa réponse et
pratique donc pour le gaming on est un
truc qui est vachement gallo rien
d'autre qu il faut venir savoir ici en
fait ici ça doit chauffer lorsque vous
jouez à des jeux et c'est le truc qui
pourrait paraître en tout cas être assez
inconfortable donc si vous craignez à
votre truc qui chauffe un petit peu et
un smartphone qui choque les gens il
faut savoir qu'à ça chauffe un peu après
il ya beaucoup de smartphones qui vont
venir chauffer comme ça donc c'est pas
le truc qui a vraiment dire ont posé
problème et qui va venir monde était ici
donc pas de souci donc pour le gaming
pour la fluidité toute cette expérience
la série très très bien de la même
manière si vous ne vous mettre un film
une série par exemple ici là sur dix
n'est plus et bien au plat ça
fonctionnera également bien donc c'est
un écran qui aussi vachement pratique
pour me regarder des films et des séries
alors comme ça des croquettes m très
allongée vous allez avoir des bandes
noires sur le côté donc si vous voulez
les éviter vous venez zoom un peu mais
si vous venez zoom et bien vous venez
croupit dans l'image que vous mangez un
peu l'image en eau est un peu c'est un
peu le l'inconvénient de ce format là
comme la plupart des films dé retrouver
là c'est sur un format 16 9ème l'écran
est beaucoup plus allongée bon à côté de
ça c'est pas très grave vous vous
rapprochez vous veniez vous êtes quand
même dans votre signe vous êtes immergés
donc ça ne dérangera pas des masses mais
je vous le disais une fois de plus en
terme d'expérience on a un très bel
écran qui mangent bien tourner
rafraîchissement variable est assez
confortable pour tout ce qui va être
gaming pour tout ce qui va être
visionnage de films de séries vous avez
un truc qui marche vraiment bien mais
qui conviendra une fois de plus très
bien pour tous les usages là à
l'extérieur ils ont gardé le même
principe je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez parce que quand je vous ai
présenté ce smartphone là c'était le
samsung galaxy z philippe n'y a pas eu 2
et philippe deux sont passés directement
sur les aides fille de 3 pour venir
claire des gammes plus cohérente parce
que là il ya eu plusieurs modèles de
galaxy z phone on a eu un petit peu
moins de flics donc ils ont harmonisé
les noms on est passé directement d'un
samsung galaxy c'est flippant 1 083 f4
en fait c'est la troisième édition est
pas la quatrième édition il y avait eu
un gros écart entre la première édition
est la deuxième édition pourquoi et bien
parce qu'au début vous aviez un tout
petit écran de type s'était pas grand
chose et l'année dernière en intégrant
ce l'écran notification beaucoup plus
grands ils sont allés plus loin c'était
vraiment intéressant donc cet écran on
garde le même principe c'est du super
amoled c'est un taux de rafraîchissement
de 60 hertz il n'y a rien de bien neuf
en fait en garde la même recette il ya
des nouveautés elle son logiciel il
vienne vraiment apporté un intérêt en
plus à ce smartphone notamment ici ce
qu'on va voir est ce qu'on n'avait pas
l'année dernière c'est à dire des petits
raccourcis pour pouvoir appeler des
personnes des personnes qui sont dans
votre répertoire par exemple vous avez
vos galaxie à buzz deux protagonistes ne
vous les mettez aux oreilles directement
et là vous venez passer un coup de fil
vous appelez directement quelqu'un dans
votre répertoire les trois personnes qui
sont à vos favoris donc ça vous évite de
venir ouvrir votre smartphone de la même
manière vous avez vos clubs de pro c'est
en train d'écouter de la musique est
quelqu'un vous appelle et bien pouvait
décrocher directement au sens pour le
faire déjà avant mais voyez le fait
d'avoir ce petit raccourci c'est quand
même pas trop mal on a quoi alors votre
musique pour venir gérer également ici
avec vos buzz à côté ok ça marche la
météo des alarmes tacul de votre manque
de parfums brève voyez quel pas mal de
choses le minuteur votre calendrier vous
venir ajouter des celle pilotée
directement vos petits bugs directement
là donc c'est plein de petites choses
qui viennent en plus et qui viennent se
rajouter au delà de ça il ya un truc qui
est vraiment intéressant au niveau de ce
smartphone c'est ce qu'on va appeler le
flex mode alors le flex mode il est
assez marrant montrent par exemple et
scission de plaistow je viens ici et là
je viens plier mon smartphone et là j'ai
mon flex mode qui apparaît alors le flex
mode c'est quoi ça raconte quoi en fait
comme histoire est bien le fait que ce
mode c'est de l' usage smartphone pillés
honnêtement de vous à moi je pense qu'il
n'y a pas réellement d'intérêt un vraie
flex mode est intéressant dans certains
usages peut-être mais on va détailler sa
sur ce smartphone là parce qu'on pouvoir
faire différentes choses avec du
multitâche sur le flex mode j'ai donc en
eau et bien mon programme un peu plus le
standard et sur le bassin espèce de
pavés noir alors là j'ai quoi te
regarder si j'appuie ici ça m'affiche
mais notification ok bon je m'en fiche
je reviens là dessus la deuxième c'est
une capture d'écran j'appuie la tacc
regarder europe là ça me fait rappeler
une fois ça me fait une petite capture
d'écran ok bon super est ce que ça ne
sert réellement d'avoir un flex mode
pour voir que les captures d'écran je ne
suis pas convaincu j'ai quoi ici mon
réglage de luminosité ok super u ou
pareil pour le son et puis le dernier
que ça peut être plus intéressant ça
transcende cette petite partie là en
fait en un petit un petit pavé souris
voyez j'ai une petite souris l'a donc là
avec un doigt je viens là je peux
naviguer je le fais à deux doigts il
faut se faire directement avec mes
doigts là le poser à plat parce que je
sens un peu relou comme ça en fait
utilisé donc il ya peut-être des usages
qui sont un peu rigolo et on pourrait
dire ah ouais cha le flex mode c'est
marrant mais ces gadgets très
honnêtement alors les ingénieurs sont
creusé la tête et sont dues au fait quel
intérêt qu est ce que cela pourrait
apporter d'avoir un smartphone qui se
plie maintient sur un flex mode est en
fait cela comme ça ça ne sert
globalement à pas grand chose alors le
flex mode il est intéressant pour autre
chose si par exemple je viens et je
prends des photos voyez je suis comme ça
et là je viens le plier légèrement donc
ça ça peut être un peu rigolo parce que
ça n'augmente mazzone d'outils
disponibles et ça me réduit mon aperçu
alors ce qui est un peu rigolo c'est
qu'effectivement eh bien voyez ça bien
s'adapter assez marrant mais pour autant
je vais perdre un peu d'image là je
manque un peu d'informations au niveau
de mon calme autre truc vous le prenez
vous le mettez comme ça vous le bouger
ça c'est pareil je perds un peu
d'informations mais après c'était rigolo
que je peut switcher à plat je mets de
côté jeu mais de l'autre donc en fait
c'est flex moi c'est plein de petits
trucs un peu rigolo mais qui en fait ne
serve globalement rien je peux me dire
je gagne poser comme ça et je me dis ben
tiens par exemple à j'ai une super idée
je pose mon smartphone je vais faire une
vidéo par exemple regardez je le pense
comme ça moi je mets de l'autre côté et
j'aime filmer sauf que en fait si je me
film doit être cotée sur la caméra
principale pour profiter des meilleurs
capteurs je m'en fous que mon retour
moniteur soit la houssoye de l'autre
côté y voyez moi ça ne m'intéresse pas
jean léger mais en fait réellement aucun
intérêt ça ne serait pas pertinent ça
n'a pas de sens s'il est seul bouton qui
est un vrai sens c'est celui là qui me
permet de l'activer
retour moniteur sur mon écran là et ça
c'est intéressant et ça c'est pertinent
mais sinon globalement il est assez peu
de parfinance donc le flex mode il est
marrant mais c'est tout ça s'arrête là
mais pour autant être ça veut dire que
ce smartphone n'a pas d'intérêt arias
plier absolument pas ce smartphone il un
vrai intérêt à venir ce billet c'est le
fait de venir le ranger facilement de
gagner de la place et de rendre plus
compact et puis l'innovation attendez on
est des technophiles si vous regardez
cette vidéo vous êtes probablement
technophiles autre que vous voulez vous
renseigner là dessus comme on entend de
technophiles j'adore sept aps les lions
j'adore la charnière j'adore le boulot
qu'il fait là dessus mais le fait de
pouvoir passer ça d'un côté ou de
l'autre le fait d'avoir un flex mode
avec beaucoup d'espacé noir je ne vois
pas d'usagé si vous voyez un usage dites
le moi dit le mât réellement en bas en
commentaire je peux le faire également
pour la calculatrice un avec les
calculatrices elle existe en flex mode
est ce que j'ai un réel intérêt là
dessus eh bien je pense que non vers des
jeux plis up et là je me retrouve avec
la même truc c'est à dire j'ai un petit
pavé où je peux venir naviguer là sans
ma calculatrice donc en fait c'est là où
konaté est ce que j'ai pas bien fait
rage en 8 + 2 égale dit rien donc ça n'a
pas d'intérêt donc voilà c'est un petit
gadget c'est marrant c'est là je pense
qu'il peut être que certaines
applications serait vraiment intéressant
pratique aller plus loin mais tel qu'il
est là sur les trucs un petit peu de
base bon on s'en fout un peu après il ya
un truc qu'ils ont fait pas mal sûr se
fixe mode c'est que vous venez
recherchez un peuple la flex devient
chercher alors pouvait mettre du multi
faudrait pour toutes les api ya pas mal
de petites choses qu'on peut venir voir
directement aux places dans le lab voler
en mode flex et là vous avez vos
différentes applications prévenir
activer désactiver pour le flex mode ou
pas calculé que les astuces les contacts
disney plus conquis et crom dont celui
des digues avec deux doigts comme ça je
ne pense pas sur ce smartphone ça n'a
pas vraiment d'intérêt voilà je peux
venir activer désactiver ce que je vaux
en flex mode ou pas donc bon bah il se
creuse la tête il propose des trucs et
bon c'est assez marrant mais le truc à
savoir ici c'est que les mises à jour
que vous avez alors au delà du fleix
mode et surtout je pense à ce que vous
allez retrouver si au niveau de cet
écran extérieur notamment le fait
d'avoir vos contacts là et bien vous
allez avoir une mise à jour sur votre
samsung galaxy explique 3 qui vous
donnera les mêmes fonctionnalités
logicielles donc si vous voulez ses
fonctionnalités là et que vous avez déjà
samsung galaxy s'infiltrant ne changeait
pas vous allez avoir les mises à jour
dont vous serez tranquille et vous
garderez un smartphone qui a exactement
le même look and feel sauf qu'il n'a pas
été retaillée ci et ça donc en fait
c'est un smartphone qui est quasiment
identique verser à ses forces oeuvraient
pour crop je dirais tout simplement
parce qu'en fait vous avez un processeur
beaucoup plus performant à l'intérieur
on allait dernier point sur de pâles
comme le plus performant à l'heure
actuelle le snapdragon 8 plus de
première génération ce qui fait qu ici
on va venir améliorer quoi une fois de
plus l'autonomie au delà de la
performance au delà quand on est des
jeux donc si vous voulez un smartphone
avec une autonomie qui sera amélioré par
rapport aux effect 3 est bien celui là
il va être amélioré et de la même
manière elles sont passées d'une
batterie de 3300 milliards terreur à
3700 milliards perdus à bord ont bien
poussé l'autonomie un peu plus loin vous
voyez ils cherchent des solutions dans
ok on a un joli smartphones les
dernières les explique trois motos nos
mirettes un peu aux fraises il fallait
recharger une fois par jour et c'était
pas top donc là on vient améliorer le
taux de rafraîchissement de 1 à 100
hertz a cédé 2,10 optimisation c'est
tout petit mais ça apporte brique après
brique un pierre après pierre le fait
d'avoir un processeur plus performant
qu'il a mieux géré toute la question de
l'autonomie c'est aussi intéressant le
fait de la rhune un peu plus grosse
batterie bon c'est pas énorme et de 3003
3007 et quand même 400 millions eur de
plus son bon on les prend tout ce qui
est bon à prendre on prend près tous en
gardons le même form factor donc c'est
pas mal c'est plutôt bien donc ce
smartphone là il va être plus performant
que le galaxy s et le fil 3 donc je
dirais que si vous inviter chez samsung
galaxy ses deux filles 3 que vous posez
la question d'aller sur les filles 4e
vous êtes technophiles parce que vous
l'êtes dernières innovations que vous
voulez le dernier modèle ma
recommandation ces noms ne fait pas
garder votre fx 3 attendait les mises à
jour et bien vous et des problèmes
d'autonomie recharger le régulièrement
alors après il ya un autre truc qui a
été fait là dessus d'un point de vue
matériel et qui peut être intéressant on
va venir se recharger un peu plus vite
on passe d'une recharge en 15 watts max
à une recharge en 25 watts max c'est pas
suffisant pour venir acheter ce nouveau
smartphone alors je trouve ça plutôt pas
mal mais on dit oui c'est de la recharge
rapide 25 watts alors je suis désolé
excusez moi mais aujourd'hui vous avez
quand même beaucoup de marques qui
proposent de la recharge rapide 65
points c'est déjà un petit moment 120
watts et on voit que ça va plus loin et
ça va arriver plus loin dans les temps à
venir donc en fait ils ont de la
recharge qui est suffisamment rapide qui
est un peu plus rapide mais c'est pas
non plus une révolution on vient
également amélioré la charge rapide sans
fil qui et pourquoi pas mais une fois de
plus le blog de charges n'est pas inclus
je vous rappelle que ça c'est la taille
de la boîte donc ça c'est pas tout
nouveau c'est depuis l'année dernière
que samsung ne vous met plus de charger
donc il faut bien les acheter en plus
mais vous pouvez avoir une recharge
rapide jusqu'à 25 watts avec le chargeur
compatible et ça il faut le savoir je
vous ai pris quelques photos vous allez
voir c'est assez marrant pourquoi lorsqu
en face à la caméra principale qu'on a
ici bien qu'on ait un capteur de 12
mégapixels et qui nous est familier 1,50
et compagnie et bien il bosse bien le
grand-angle normal standard bosse très
bien et il ya aussi un beau boulot
algorithmique g vraiment nul chercher le
soleil à droite à gauche on a quand même
bien la façade en face ultra grand-angle
et bien aussi mais c'est pas forcément
ce que je me recommander rester sur
votre grand temps voulu très longtemps
que c'est pour les bâtiments vous êtes
vous passez de beaucoup des spasmes et
regardez on peut venir zoomer également
mais une fois de plus même en flotte de
voiliers je viens pas recommandée comme
vous n'avez pas de télé objectifs ici je
recommande pas devenir zoomer
rapprochez-vous dans la mesure du
possible ou mais légèrement parce que ça
vient dégrader assez rapidement la
qualité regardez on a le soleil là bas
ça éclaire les façades les bâtiments
c'est très cool ça marche vraiment bien
ça fera le taf très grand angle bon donc
le zoom histoire d'eux pour se marrer il
a regardé avec tout le soleil derrière
enclave pauvre et moins jeunes et qu'on
a le soleil ici on voit bien sur la
façade qui a éclairé par le soleil et on
a bien le contour du bâtiment donc une
fois de plus c'est un très beau capteurs
qui marche bien on fait très jolies
choses avec je me souvenais zoom est
donc le x 2 on peut venir un petit pont
bien trop peu dans l'image mais pas plus
comme c'est que hill 12 mégapixels on va
éviter parce que ça dégrade tout de
suite ça me donne faim ça faut que
j'arrête de regarder des trucs là mais
voyez on sort des gens qui sont très
sympas on a de jolies photos c'est un
bon photophone c'est pas le meilleur
photophone c'est pas le mieux que
propose le samsung ici mais pour autant
le boulot est plutôt bien fait sur le
capteur principal et je pense
aujourd'hui quasiment que soit leur
principal et même lorsque la luminosité
vient à baisser en mode guinguette ou
pas et bien on regarde les photos qui
sont de bonne qualité sur le capteur
principal journal une fois de plus place
des vosges parce que j'adore cette place
et ça marche clairement ses jolies donc
pour moi la photo est plutôt bien
maîtrisée là c'est vraiment la nuit
c'est la lune que vous avez en face pour
là il a eu un peu plus de mal parce que
c'est un peu poussif mais ça c'est le
problème de tous les smartphones
aujourd'hui ils veulent que la nuit face
à toujours et ça marche pas et la caméra
de celle fille est pas complètement
dingue voyez on a un côté un peu voilent
la fin de dépôt et pas très très belle
donc tout ce qu'on va sortir avec la
caméra de celle fils et pas
nécessairement quelque chose que je
viens vous recommander côté vidéo son
capteur principal c'est assez fluide ça
marche pas trop mal c'est pas le
meilleur smartphone pour faire de la
vidéo mais voyez venir ajouté quelques
trucs ça quelque chose pour les réseaux
sociaux ça marche parce que vous le
prenez vous le mettez pour le coup en
flex molle sur les réseaux sociaux
pouvaient vous filmez d'un côté et de
l'autre et vous sortez des choses qui
sont corrects très correct pour les
réseaux donc ça ira très très bien comme
ça la caméra de celle fit pas terrible
même en vidéo c'est pas ouf et voyez si
non c'est assez bien c'est assez fluide
on peut venir faire deux choses bon en
terme de qualité ici par un flou ça
reste un smartphone ça marche bien ce
n'est pas le meilleur capteur que nous
amis samsung ici et pour autant le
résultat est très honnête au niveau de
la photo soit capteur principal la vidéo
ça va c'est pas dingue mais sanaa alors
c'est un smartphone qui a du wifi 6
alors ça c'est bien mais ça me fait
râler parce que on est ici que sur du
wifi si sais pas si vous avez vu mais il
ya plusieurs marques notamment au bout
de télécoms avec qui je suis partenaire
qui a sorti sa box ou wifi 6e ça apporte
des débits plus rapides ça va aller un
peu plus vite et je trouve ça dommage
sur un smartphone à plus de 1100 euros
il nous est pas mais du wifi si ce qui
reste un homme bouffi six mois ici c'est
très bien attention ça va vite n'y a pas
de souci mais on va quand même vachement
plus vite avec du wifi 6e il acheva sur
un smartphone à 1100 balle et ça ça fait
râler alors par contre sur le z folle de
4g du wifi si ce don qui se disent ok on
vient décliner les gammes c'est qu'un
travail de guerre maintenant ils peuvent
très bien être la thur je pense pas
qu'il ya un surcoût énorme c'est juste
une question de gamme en disant on vient
vraiment différencier le gamme plus
professionnel où on est le all in et
tout ce qui a notamment bouffer 6e et là
c'est un tour un peu plus lifestyle n'y
a pas besoin de bouffer scission va pas
le mettre je trouve ça un peu con très
honnêtement ça aurait été bien de le
mettre là dedans d'autant plus que ça se
démocratise de plus en plus donc que bon
si vous avez la dernière box de bouygues
telecom nos ipad ou ici ce dommage pour
la réforme cas ici alors vous avez quand
même de la 5g ça c'est plutôt bien c'est
un smartphone qui résistant aux
éclaboussures
ipx8 attention c'est pas de l'ipé 68-67
donc on va pas aller aussi loin que
d'autres smartphones un peu plus
standards notamment les samsung galaxy s
22 s m du travail compagnie néanmoins
s'il rencontre un peu d'eau ça devrait
bien se passer alors moi j'aime beaucoup
ce smartphone j'aime beaucoup une fois
de plus cette idée du smartphone qui est
extrêmement jolie qu'on peut venir
customiser ce côté extrêmement lifestyle
trouve ça hyper canon libé de
l'écosystème samsung avec une monde
connecté qui va vraiment devenir match
et avec vos smartphones sur sa très cool
vous avez notamment ses tongs watch cinq
défauts que la recharge la galaxie web
s'inquiéterait coup la galaxie walsh
cinq pros qui est très bien aussi pense
pas mais on va détailler dans quelques
jours donc si vous n'êtes pas abonné
abonnez-vous comme ça vous saurez tout
on se parle également des galaxies buzz
deux pros il yal thèse qui arrive je
trouve aussi super bien et super bien
réussi et une vraie belle intégration
entre le logiciel le matériel les
différents matériaux et je trouve ça
très chouette alors il ya un petit truc
qui me fait un peu marre et que je vous
avais pas montrer c'est en fait ce
smartphone là il est un petit peu aimant
et un peu plus que le modèle de l'année
dernière c'est à dire que si vous
croisez des pièces et bien
potentiellement poser sur la table vous
posez votre téléphone sue et pas vu pas
pris vous récupérez le pognon ça me fait
marrer c'est un petit peu un détail il
est un peu plus aimante et qu'il allait
d'ailleurs on passe très rapidement donc
j'aime beaucoup cette proposition pour
moi c'est un smartphone super chouette
donc si vous voulez un smartphone
pliable de samsung que vous n'en avez
jamais eu vous pouvez aller sur le
samsung galaxy z fit quatre je vous
recommande je vais pas forcément
recommander les filles 3 même s'il reste
au catalogue de samsung pour les
questions d'autonomie donc rajouter un
peu plus d'argent est passé sur cette
nouvelle génération qui aura une
autonomie améliorée tu auras un peu plus
de performances et puis vu le tarif
mieux vaut quand même la dernière
génération je trouve bien je trouve bien
réussi c'est une belle évolution du
samsung galaxy ces flics 3 sans être
pour autant une vraie révolution est un
vrai changement ce qui est cool c'est la
personnalisation ce qui est cool c'est
le design et l'expérience qu'on a avec
le flex qui se plie même si pour autant
d'un point de vue logiciel on ne fera
pas grand chose voilà donc dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous aimez ces
smartphones cette proposition de
smartphones qui se plie comme ça est ce
que vous avez déjà acheté à samsung
galaxy z flip 3 l'année dernière vous
êtes fait plutôt début marc et moi ça
juste en bas en commentaire puis est ce
que ça vous intéresse et ce que vous
pourriez venir vous positionnez oui ou
non marquée -5 on se retrouve très vite
et vous l'avez compris pour continuer à
parler et bien de samsung avec le fold
quatre galaxies cette folle de 4 les
bugs on parle de monde on parle de tout
et ça c'est chouette sur ce je vous
embrasse pour la soif vous et puis à
très bientôt des bureaux l'amour ciao
[Musique]